the Marvel Cinematic Universe the vast
narrative that grows more expansive and
complex with each movie directors Joe
and Anthony Russo managed to work a
healthy chunk of that universe into
Avengers endgame but there is an always
room for everyone as much as we wanted
to see them here's what we didn't see
these characters an endgame stellan
skarsgård dr. Erik Selvig who can't
boast any magical powers or hi-tech
suits of armor but he was intregal early
on the MCU appearing in the first two
Thor films as well as the first two
Avengers movies we last saw Selvig in
2015's age of Ultron helping for
recapture his vision of the Infinity
stones a week before end games premiere
skarsgård confirmed he wasn't part of
the cast I've done for Marvel films and
they have me contracted for five and
they haven't called me yet they usually
call me when they need some weird plot
to be explained in a quasi scientific
way so begins at the MCU as part of
Thor's entourage that was before the
game-changing Thor Ragnarok which was
the first entry of the Thor franchise to
not involve him Natalie Portman or kat
dennings it was also unquestionably the
most successful in that franchise
Ragnarok success made skarsgård part of
a Thor paradigm that the MCU may not be
interested in anymore as soon as it was
revealed that Game of Thrones star Peter
Dinklage would appear in Avengers
infinity war there was wild speculation
about who the actor would play a brief
exchange in a preview clip left fans
incorrectly believing that Dinklage was
voicing black or a member Corvus glaive
Dinklage was instead revealed as III the
dwarf the forge master of new devaglia
who made me all near and whom Thor seeks
out for a new weapon he doesn't appear
in endgame and we don't even know if
Eitri survives the decimation whether he
does or not still be left alone on
Nineveh Leia since all is dwarven
brethren were killed before the snap
even happened he killed everyone
anywhere except me presumably with
Stormbreaker made and the first battle
with Thanos fought and last eat trees
work in the infinity saga was over but
it would be gratifying to find out how
the forge master is faring when Steve
Rogers and Tony Stark lose a tesseract
to Loki and the force to go back to 1970
to get their hands on the space stone we
get to see some old friends tony is
reunited with a young Howard Stark and
we even get a brief conversation between
Howard and Edwin Jarvis from agent
Carter
Peggy Carter herself as accounted for as
well when cut notices her through an
office window and the digitally D H
Michael Douglas appears as hank pym when
rogers visits his lab conspicuously
absent as toby jones s Arnim Zola
viewers might not have even taken note
of the absence but when Howard first
runs into Tony he's looking for the
Hydra veteran Zola likely doesn't appear
because it wouldn't serve the plot of an
already crowded film there's also a
convenience narrative explanation for
his absence in Captain America the
Winter Soldier the Zola
AI explains why he lives in a computer
in 1972 I received a terminal diagnosis
science could not save whatever that
diagnosis was as possible he was already
suffering its effects in 1970 which
could go a long way to what explaining
why he wasn't at work that day to
capture the power stone nebula and war
machine traveled to more rack in 2014
just as Peter quill was about to nab it
in the beginning of guardians of the
galaxy and like that earlier film German
Han Sue's Kree warrior Cora doesn't show
up with his soldiers to attempt to get
the orb back from Quayle narrative Lee
the reason for core wife's absence can
be explained by an unfortunate
development for the Avengers sending
nebula back to 2014 has he unintended
consequence Butler ting the fans at that
time what the Avengers are up to once a
nose forces to take the signal from
nebula they set course for Morag and
eventually capture her so while korra
who works for ronan who was working for
Thanos is heading to Morag Thanos
himself as enroute to the Kree Warrior
wouldn't be dumb enough to try to get in
thunders way once he learns he shares a
destination with his boss's boss the
trio Hank Pym calls the Wombats in
ant-man skilled storyteller Lewis played
by Michael Pena Kurt played by David dis
Mochan and Dave played by TI
don't show up in the film you could
argue Louisa's at least they're in
spirits as we hear his famous musical
car horn several times but the group
themselves choose to as they say back it
up
while Louise has proven he's got a punch
you do not want to be on the receiving
end of neither Curt nor Dave of
showiness that be very effective against
alien soldiers or other super-powered
baddies so that one bats would be little
help against Thanos his forces still an
alternate version of endgame that simply
Louise's retelling of the events would
be a great time when Thor and rocket go
back to the events of Thor the dark
world to retrieve the ether the Thunder
God has what proves to be a much-needed
reunion with his mother Frigga who later
that day is fated to lose her life
though she appears in both of the first
two Thor films Frigga might have wound
up getting more and more lines and
screen time and ends game than in the
two earlier films combined Thor doesn't
get to see his father Odin however at
this point - the emcee used timeline
Odin is in denial about his son's place
in Asgard and the return of the Dark
Elves
and soon he'll be in denial about his
chances against the Dark Elves when
Frigga speaks with Thor her husband is
likely meeting with his generals about
the invasion that won't happen the
absence of Jaime Alexander's safe in
Avengers endgame is an indicator we've
seen our last of the character in the
MCU Alexander is also conspicuously
absent from 2017 so Ragnarok Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige explained
that Loki disguised as Odin wouldn't
want Thor's closed his allies to
threaten his rule so when he accuses
Heimdall of treason he also exiles safe
from Asgard the real-world reason for
absence was much simpler scheduling
according to Alexander Marvel waited
until the last minute to ask her to
appear in Ragnarok at which point
Marvel's shooting schedule conflicted
with that of Alexander's NBC series
blind spots as a vent game asifa still a
no-show she isn't with the refugees in
new Asgard and she doesn't appear at the
final battle with the resurrected heroes
by the end of the film Thor has headed
back to the stars
so it's possible we might see a reunion
but as the years tick by it feels less
and less likely that one of the MC used
fiercest warrior women will return Phil
Coulson played by Clark Gregg is killed
by Loki in 2012 Avengers but like a true
Marvel hero he's resurrected in time to
star in Marvel's agents of shield but if
you didn't watch the Marvel's TV shows
you'd never know that considering how
famously fractured the movie and
television size of the MCU have been
Coulson has been cinematically dead
since Avengers still ever since this
traumatic televised revival of fans of
the
see you have wondered whether Colson
would ever get the chance let his old
friends know he was back it sure seems
like endgame is just about the last
chance Colson has to give the Avengers
an f.y.i
but Coulson's nowhere to be seen in
endgame and agents of shields faith
season ends with Coulson learning he is
dying he chooses to retire to Tahiti
with Melinda may to further complicate
things in season six Coulson will be
dead and Gregg will play a new character
to include Coulson in endgame the
filmmakers would need to explain
Coulson's confusing status to film
audiences along with everything else on
their to-do list for endgame all parties
probably agreed it was best for him to
stay on the TV side of things for now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the Avengers are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]